was es geht so herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der show heute abend
den man live mit dabei was habe ich ja
schon gesagt ich mein headset show
möchten direkt mit erst nach in
sendungen wie stammt vom februar und
heißt der hat was hat er an
zumindest der an also der hat wohnsitze
packe ich dachte spectators kälter da
fliegt aber so bin ich auch nicht mal so
ein kleid hätte
also said zurückgebracht ist alter ich
sehe jetzt gestorben einen chat ist
gestorben
hier gehen wir zurück das ist anderer
meinung also zurück importiert das weckt
bei aber der andere täter ist das für
ein server was passiert ja kummer hd ist
einfach komma die größte deutsche server
einen der größten zwar weltweit
und ja dass das minecraft to basics die
leute einfach aus dem nichts aber so
stunden ein komplettes stelle noch
einmal so man könnte natürlich wieder
rätseln was er jetzt wahr was er sich
dann neu zugelegt hat pferde und wieder
hoch zu fliegen
platz 2 heißt amadé punkt net hecking
flavio 177 neuer flagge wie nett die
passende hose
hallo mein freund florian i was at it
meiner und wir wirklich die drastik
experten dabei doch sonst geben uns mehr
bis zu bieten geprägt ist so lächerlich
wenn so hecker weg bauen
der fliegt ja und warum baut ihr wenn
ihr in der luft fliegt ein weg damit die
leute sich bemerken dass die hecken
stimmt
das video aber hallo mein freund bruder
danke wir wussten dass kann das nach
regeln schreibt jetzt die kommentare
müssen es ganz schlecht nach unter
bleibt also nicht gegen das ist halt
natural bodybuilding rocket hetzel alter
500 euro das ist 600 euro kosten hat
seid ihr sicher
ach du scheiße das hardware analyse
thema daraus genannte christian seitz
leitet keine hexe
okay heute platz drei okay wir haben
einfach die plätze 3 bis 29/2 kannst du
mit deinem hauptlager auch nicht mehr
spielen warum sollte ich nicht mehr
spielen es sind gerade am anfang der
sendung tatsächlich am anfang der
einsendung und eddie demonstriert er
macht so richtig auf abfahrt schlägt ihn
so zwei mal so richtig los wer ist
gestorben eines instant am start alter
es gibt nein ein fremder ein enthalte
alter junge wie die am start sind wasser
der vorder auf jeden fall die
demonstriert hier die hochqualitative
plastikfolie unter seinem gelben studien
team dazu bringt dir so das war
wahrscheinlich silvester an dem tag nach
dessen rakete soll neuer hecke
silvesterraketen hecken formuliert dass
zuerst gesehen silvesterraketen heck
ermöglicht durch eine plastik unterlage
unter auch im game im stuhl jetzt zu
kaufen auch sk shop.de bald wie handy
1234 oder freddy 5364 teil sehr bekannt
beide sehr gut
warum
lässig leute platz zwei essen classic
fanny hacker auf dem server all cap von
tom youtube in den kanal übel
was ist über fünf prozent zu erwarten
er muss seinen kopf ein hey hey es
folgen porträts mit pocket ethische
connect ob 88 ein wunder was geht ab
nächsten buch gesehen wer sein kopf
einfach
weil ich bereit euch vor und 32 ich kann
auch ist es ein fucking what dafür dass
man seinen kopf so verbiegen kann beim
normalen minecraft kannst du das ja auch
also partout das geht nicht so zu liegen
vor allem die wii gerade sein fenster zu
hause aus ist es dann auch ruhig auf dem
kopf ich glaub ich glaube nicht ich hab
nicht wir können uns jetzt die
einzigartige nummer für mich als papa
und ich bin auch sagen nummer eins aber
hört nicht auf die platz 17 leute stammt
von fabian heißt die caps einfach
schreien
ob ich für diese verlieren aber es gut
alter wie pingpong mit dem das nicht
fünf gegner
und wer wie schlecht wir sind die alle
das bett abgebaut und das ganze team
rausgeworfen
wer einbricht
[ __ ] my life junge ein ganzes dorf
einfach gegen eine hecke und auch
getötet
ja der hat gerade einfach mit seinem
fucking mac client zwei teams im
alleingang auseinander genommen 28 teams
wohlgemerkt stimmt ist nicht wesentlich
40 56 sind acht leute ein paar wörter zu
verlieren wie er hier so diese leistung
bringen kann
wie ist das möglich von equipment seite
her können wir kurz spezialisten
bekommen alles klar war ich hab hier
lightning auf hdmi adapter kit durch
eine sehr teure maus an alles klar ist
laufen also also ich hab gehört extrem
häufig speed dank super teurem aus jacke
eigenbau vergoldet verchromt verwächst
verbietet ich habe gehört dass man um
diese performance zu bringen zwischen 40
und 50 extra tasten auf seiner gaming
mouse haben muss was dann dazu führt
dass die das ding nicht bereichen leute
ganz ehrlich doch pleite am sonntag ist
einfach noch nicht genug
wir machen dich jetzt doch okay fand
genau hin alte ok folgte sg ops map jet
wollten wir auf snapshot escape und
jetzt kommt euch das ist heute in der
shisha bar passiert okay die richtige
mein name ist obwohl manager war
verabredet er mit dem fucking porsche
kann viel besser aus dem stadtsäckel und
das hier ist entstanden als ich fest
mit dieser kleinen dosis zyklopen swag
entlassen wir euch in das ende eures
wochenendes